back to sort of a serious question why
do you think it's hard to get outside of
our solar system it's just an energy
calculus i mean
you can do it slowly
uh whenever you want um but uh
the idea of getting there in you know
one lifetime or multiple
a few lifetimes is requires huge amounts
of energy to
to accelerate
and then you've as soon as you get
halfway there you need to expend an
equal amount of energy to decelerate or
you'll just go shooting by
and so um
that means carrying a lot of energy and
there's there's uh ideas like yuri
milner
i think is still funding the the idea to
use laser
propulsion to send something uh to
another star system a small object
but it'll have no way to slow down
as far as i know they never talk about
that part yeah like how do we slow down
yeah um
so it's a quick flyby you take a good
picture i guess yeah you better take
some good pictures on your way by so and
that's great if it happens i'm not
knocking it um but
the amount of energy is is that's needed
is just staggering and there's there's
other issues like just how do you
maintain
uh
an ecosystem for that long in isolation
uh how do you prevent people from going
crazy what happens if you hit something
while traveling at a significant
fraction of the speed of light what
about it sort of
some combination of expanding human
lifespan but also just good
old-fashioned
stable society on a spaceship yeah yeah
the generation ship yeah yeah yeah no i
think that's the only way it would it
would have to keep going for a long time
and they might get to where they're
going and find
a shitty
solar system like we can try to
we can try to do some advanced survey
but
i mean if you get there
and all the planets in that solar system
are just garbage planets then it's kind
of a big letdown
for for this like thousand-year voyage
that you've just uh you've just been on
right so i mean we have a pretty narrow
range of
of parameters that we need to stay uh
between in order to survive um in terms
of the gravitational uh field that we
can deal with
so that such a sets of bound on the size
of the the planet
and
what we need in the way of temperature
and atmosphere and so on
so
when you look at all those complications
then basically
building uh
sort of
exactly the environment we want out of
available materials in this solar system
starts to look a hell of a lot better
it's hard to make uh um
an economic argument let's say for for
for making that journey
uh one of the things i like about the
expanse is the fact that the people who
are trying to build the starship to go
to the other solar system are doing it
for religious reasons i think that's the
only reason that you would do it
because economically it just makes more
sense to build
rotating cylindrical space habitats and
make them perfect
well is isn't everything done for
religious reasons like why do we
exploration yeah like what why why do we
go to the moon again
and do the other things uh what does jfk
said it's because not because they're
easy but because they're hard it's not
kind of a religious reason
i knew a veteran of the apollo program
who once said that the apollo moon
landings were communism's greatest
achievements
yeah so the conflict between nations is
a kind of um
this is exactly a religion but it's what
you're talking about well it's a
struggle for meaning yeah i mean uh and
that meaning isn't found in some kind of
it's it's hard to find meaning in
mathematics yeah it's it's found in some
kind of
in music and religion whatever art i
mean some people do
but those are
probably not enough of them to
well they uh people that find beauty uh
meaning in mathematics they usually find
meaning between the lines nevertheless
not in the actual
uh
form of like the proving
proving some kind of thing fair enough
yeah so
from a cost perspective do you actually
see a possible future where we're be
building these kind of generation ships
and just
why not launch them one a year
out
like uh like wandering ants into the
into the galaxy
i have nothing against it uh it's just
like i said it's got a
the motivation to do it has to come from
some kind of spiritual or
or kind of non-tangible
uh calculus from a business model
perspective you don't think there's a
business model there no no way
you